this episode of the minimalist is
brought to you by
nobody because advertisements suck
this podcast has bad words
hello everybody welcome to the
minimalist podcast where we discuss what
it means to live a meaningful life for
the less
my name is joshua fields milburn and i'm
ryan nicodemus and together we are the
minimalist and there's a reason we're on
the same camera today if you're watching
this on youtube
we just had to be next to each other
we've never done this before there are
three guests in the studio and
you can't tell we're all appropriately
distanced so don't worry all right
today we're going to talk about the 2020
election uh so i think this is actually
come out a day early ryan so we're going
to get this a day
out a day before the election we want to
talk about the current political divide
we want to talk about how we can find
unity even when we disagree
and so we've got some folks here we may
agree with who may disagree with
and by the end of this episode we'll all
tell you who you should vote for
uh kim iverson's here from the kim
iverson show on youtube i think the only
political show i still watch so thank
you
tk coleman revolution of one jamie
kilstein is here your your new podcast
title keeps throwing me off it's a
fuckups guide to self-help fuck-ups
yeah there's no metaphor that is what
that is what it is i am a fuck-up and i
am helping people
so we're here today to talk about the uh
the sort of fallout uh what's what's
about to happen
we don't know actually what's going to
happen the reason that one of the five
of us here is i suspect while i don't
know this
i suspect all five of us may have voted
differently
this year i haven't voted yet okay i'm
voting on election day uh-huh
nice so so so by the time it's like no
christmas eve present we're doing it on
the [ __ ]
doing it on the day i'm actually voting
the day after so
yeah i think someone tricked you but
do you they said it was wednesday as
long as it's postmarked by
like look like a trump would be my
question
all right so here's the reason i wanted
the five of us to be here
i think we all think differently but we
don't let our preferences
ruin our relationships with other people
yeah and
and i've i've noticed that with the
three of you like we can
i say kim's show is the only show i
watch regularly about politics we
probably agree
40 to 60 of the time on things feel like
that number's gone down last time i saw
you i feel like that was maybe
80 80. maybe it keeps changing
whatever we agree like there's obviously
amount of time that we disagree
on on things right it doesn't mean
there's a right or wrong necessarily and
and i wanted to start today because i
want to really give the floor to you all
so this is probably going to be the last
time i do much
speaking i want to talk about the
problem with labels because i could very
easily say well
the reason i wanted kim and tk and jamie
to be on as we have
a progressive a libertarian and
um there's a [ __ ] libertarian here
i'm out i'm out
i don't know that i wouldn't hold that
and i think they're called lol butarians
now
but i could say we have a progressive a
libertarian and a liberal here and what
do all those things mean but i'm gonna
talk about the problem with labels so
this is from a book by anthony demelo
called awareness by the way this is my
added value today because we're gonna
skip that we're not gonna have a bunch
of time
so um added value segment today right
now
anthony demelo's awareness i want to
read this section about labels
it's on page 37 here awareness without
evaluating everything
do you want to change the world how
about beginning with yourself
how about being transformed yourself
first
but how do you achieve that through
observation through understanding
through no interference or judgment on
your part because
what you judge you cannot understand
when you say of someone he's a communist
understanding
has only has stopped at that moment
you slapped a label on him she's a
capitalist
understanding has stopped at that moment
you slapped a label on her
and if the label carries undertones of
approval or disapproval
so much the worse how are you going to
understand what you disapprove of
or what you approve of for that matter
all this sounds like a new world doesn't
it
no judgment no commentary no attitude
one simply observes one studies
one watches without the desire to change
what is because if you desire to change
what
is and to into what you think should
be you no longer understand
i want to start with that because i
think we have a great divide right now
and the reason that i love the three of
you is you have
the opportunity to talk to some folks
today who are
feeling some discontent around our
current
disunification and it's not about
liberal conservative left right red blue
personally i don't care who you voted
for
um what i care about is who you are as a
person right
and so i wanted to talk today about
where we are
right now in fact during the maximal
episode we're going to review my ballot
and i think one of you may even try to
talk me out of voting
um we're going to talk about that as
well
i also wanted to go i was considering
since election day is right here
i was considering to see how many days i
could go without figuring out who won
but i don't know if i'm going to
actually do that um i mean that sounds
great
it does i really love that as a
minimalist challenge
that's like that's like a spa day that's
amazing
yeah you should you should i'm curious
okay
yeah well i'm gonna get into a bunker
i'm gonna have to stay off social media
you are gonna try oh yeah yeah
i i was just talked into it i'll do it
with you yeah i'll be with you all right
we're gonna see how many days or weeks
or months we can go yeah we
we should keep it up like on twitter or
whatever and we'll or like without
looking
oh rob yeah yeah
all right yeah i'm in man i want to try
this all right well let's start we don't
have voicemails today we have some
questions from our patreon folks let's
start with mike
if your values aren't aligned with
either of the
major party candidates is voting for a
third party candidate
really a wasted vote now kim you've
talked about this
uh extensively on your channel let's
talk about this wasted votes third
parties
undecideds what are your thoughts yeah
there's no such thing as a wasted vote
your vote is your vote
and uh you know i mean that's how we
actually voice our opinions right so
if you are constantly just stuck in this
two-party paradigm and you're going with
one or the other and that's it
then how are we ever voicing to the two
parties that were unsatisfied with them
yeah the only way is to cast a vote
right that's the only real thing we've
got so we have to cast that vote for the
third party or the right in
in order to say i don't like either of
you and send that message
whether you know then people say oh well
then that means you know which and i get
it all the time because i
i do plan when i do go in and vote to
to either write in or to vote a third
party i haven't quite decided yet
and um you know i hear it all the time
that people say oh well then that's a
vote for trump
right i get that one a lot yeah but then
from the other side i get well that's a
vote for biden
right right right i always think that
um it's a cop-out for people who go
after
third-party voters um i covered ralph
nader
when uh during the first george w bush
election got the interview and got to
sit with him and
it was so interesting because a lot of
democrats that i talked to
aligned so much more with nader than
they did with al gore
and instead of seeing a problem with the
democratic party
and the establishment and going oh why
do the people who claim to represent me
actually not represent me and i have
more in common
with the the the the seat belt guy um
they would people got so mad at nader
instead of getting
mad at the system and i just want to say
like i'm terrified
uh i'm not a fan of trump uh i'm gonna
vote for biden i'm not a fan of biden
i want i tweeted this yesterday i want
biden to win so i can go back to
criticizing biden without getting
[ __ ] from my liberal friends um
and i just feel like okay the bar but i
voted for nader i voted for kucinich
during the primaries because they
aligned
more um with who i believed in and
well i think what we saw with going from
hillary clinton
to joe biden is that the democratic
establishment
didn't really learn their lesson and
hillary should have wiped the floor with
donald trump
um even though again i don't agree with
a lot of uh of clinton's and they didn't
learn and so
sometimes it does take protest uh to do
it and people who are
still you know i still see people on
twitter oh i hope you're happy jill
stein
i hope you're happy like susan sarandon
i'm like you're stop going after
the old actor lady and the green party
like it's our establishment that is
broken that has brought us here
that is why people would vote for
someone like donald trump like we
screwed up it's not susan saranton's
fault
right ck let's uh what are we going to
talk to mike about here
um he said his views don't don't align
with either major party candidate
is voting for a third party candidate a
wasted vote
i know how you feel but can you express
to me how you feel
yeah so imagine going to a restaurant
and there are only two items on the menu
there's i love this restaurant
one item what if both of them are filled
with gluten though
well i can't go to the restaurant well
so this restaurant is
[Laughter]
so you're at a restaurant you got two
choices both of them have gluten that's
that's the starting okay
very unpopular restaurant
[Laughter]
all right just skip to the three minute
mark to get past my comments
um there's the [ __ ] sandwich and then
there's the piss milkshake
and you look at that menu and you say i
don't like either one of these but you
know i got to get something i came out
to the restaurant
uh i think i'd rather eat [ __ ] than
drink piss and so
you ordered this sandwich definitely not
i can't believe you'd vote for yourself
this thing tastes like crap
i do want to know everybody's answer to
what you would pick the pissed milkshake
obviously
yes obviously
so wait is trump the pissed milkshake or
just find the pismo chick
all right why could you get through it
faster yes and like it blends in there's
other
it's just [ __ ] on bread oh this is
supposed to be the intelligent like
political episode right
um all right back to z yes
okay so you order the piss milkshake
because you think to yourself well at
least that's not as bad mm-hmm there's
ice cream in there
right now right
a yeah sentiment now i'm in now i want
to piss milkshake i'm going to be happy
if you think about the buying decisions
you make
as a signal that you're emitting to the
marketplace
you are essentially incentivizing the
restaurant to never change
because the message you're sending to
the marketplace is no matter how
crappy my options are i will always
force myself to put up with it before i
challenge you to do better the only way
you get a restaurant that says man
if i want to stay in business if i want
to maintain people's respect and loyalty
i got to change something here and add a
third option or a fourth option
because the people aren't choosing what
i'm presenting to them
and i believe the same way as
politically you know our politics
reflects
our consciousness as a people and if we
continue to force ourselves to accept
one of the two options on the table
no matter how much we dislike them
because we buy into this philosophy that
says it is a waste to do anything else
yeah
then we are never going to create change
you've heard this cliche before that
the definition of insanity is doing the
same thing over and over
and expecting a different result and
what do we hear every election every
election
every election we hear people say oh but
this one's different
i hear what you're saying tk all right
this is what the audience is saying
right now i hear what you're saying tk
and i totally get that
in a perfect election year but this is
the most important election in history
and what i say to that is
every election can't be the most
important one in history
at some point we have to exercise the
bravery and the courage
to deviate from the narratives of fear
and say i'm willing to put up with a
little pain a little criticism a little
inconvenience
in order to send a signal to the
political marketplace saying i want
something different
now i will say one more thing which is
and i don't disagree with any of that
um but just because i only talked about
third party and my first answer
what i do want to point out is it is
possible so with barack obama right
barack obama was
a a center-left state senator
from uh chicago he was always
much more moderate than people thought
he was um
and a lot of really important reform
you know i mean just same-sex marriage
like lgbt rights like happened under
obama because
people uh demanded it
right and i think that
if you so i'm just gonna say for me uh
so i
align more with uh with liberals not a
huge fan of joe biden
but if you do feel like your third party
vote is wasted
or that this election is important but
you're like i really don't like joe
biden or i really don't like trump
you can still vote for that person put
your team
quote-unquote and i hate using that word
but you get it a little bit ahead like
set the bar to kind of what aligns with
you
and then like i'm gonna vote for biden
and then i'm gonna protest the [ __ ] out
of biden
and be like hey these are the things
that your party demands and for me
being liberal trying to get the
establishment left
to actually represent uh the left a
little more to represent the american
people so
i think that people underestimate
protest i mean did you ever think we
would see
hillary clinton talking about black
lives matter i mean she straight up
like was pulling some like racist uh
rhetoric when she was running against
obama but the people demanded
that these issues matter to us that
what's happening to black people in the
street matter to us and suddenly you see
hillary clinton
being like we have to support black
lives matter so even outside of the
election booth the people's voice does
make a
difference um you just have to be loud
and demanded and be like hey i voted for
you
now this is what i expect you know it's
hard but it it
you can still protest without uh having
a protest vote necessarily
you just actually have to you can't just
sit back and and relax and i think to
your point too a lot of people are happy
voting for biden
and they're like all right i'm done see
you in four years and that's why a lot
of these disappointments with obama
happen people were so excited about
obama
that they forgot to hold him accountable
and so suddenly a lot of these policies
that we thought we were going to have
with obama you know the way he treated
whistleblowers
i mean a whole host of things um people
were really disappointed and it's like
we kind of let him get away with that we
voted and then we pieced out you know
you know in theory uh i love what tk is
saying and in practice i love what
you're saying
it's like uh if we don't vote for a
third party or
abstain from voting for either party no
matter how you do it it's like how will
it ever change but in the same token
we live in this world where it's like
we're almost
uh forced to figure out what to do
with with the vote that we have like
yeah what we all agree on is that we
need change
is that systematically where the the
system is broken for sure
ryan in theory i love you brother
i love you in theory and in practice i'm
interested to hear what came out to say
about holly's question here
is it okay to minimize politics in my
life and ignore the social media posts
the news and the debates that feel very
toxic or is it my responsibility as a
citizen
to be well informed and confident in my
political opinions
well there's a few few words that stand
out to me in here responsibility
[Music]
hmm and kim the reason this question is
fascinating and why
we picked it here and especially for you
is you're
you do a political show so you're sort
of forced to have this
information disinformation anxiety
thrust upon you on a sort of daily basis
yeah and it's really and it is very
stressful uh and it's important i think
to always find ways to
completely detach and unplug from from
the the narratives that are out there i
don't think it's anybody's
i think it's your responsibility as an
individual to know
about the issue so that you can cast an
informed vote
but beyond that i don't think you have
any responsibility to engage
with anybody else about politics i don't
think you have to
get involved in the mudslinging because
that's what it really has kind of boiled
down to
out in social media is just a bunch of
mudslinging so i don't think anybody has
any responsibility or
uh or you know should they you know they
must get involved i don't think they
need to they just need to know the
issues for themselves
and i personally surround myself uh my
closest friends
my relationship my best friends those
people in my close inner circle are not
political at all
and they are the people that they are
informed so they cast their
and i don't even know who they're voting
for i don't even know who the person i'm
in a relationship with
i don't know who they're voting for i
have literally no idea
who he's voting for and it's but i know
he's very informed i know he knows way
more about the propositions than even i
do
but nonetheless conversations
probably probably i'll probably open up
who did you vote for
yeah i i i feel the same way like
i have no idea who jordan is voting for
i'm he's maybe writing himself in if i
had to guess
anything um kanye and
well i mean that's the thing like i said
there's five of us at this table like i
know ryan and i are voting differently
i know my wife and i are voting
differently yeah and
i know tk and i are voting differently
because one of us isn't voting um
although let's talk about that um that's
all we always talk about like
um voting not voting etc in fact we have
voting uh we had a question here about
um when is it okay
not to vote it's from our maximum up so
we might as well go ahead and ask it now
oh can i see something for holly then
real quick yeah go for it because so
my life has changed dramatically and it
totally revolves around holly's question
where i used to be
very political tweeting every day
getting into fights with like
politicians and journalists and i
thought i was doing
this great job and when it comes to
responsibility the only responsibility
that i take on now is
being a good person and leading with
like love and even though i was more
active politically
back then i was a shittier person i was
ignoring the clerk at the grocery store
because i was tweeting my hot take and
now
like everyone at the grocery store knows
me by name because i have conversations
with them
and but i strongly think that makes you
a good person
i think that in my day-to-day life i am
a
kinder person who is making the people
who i encounter with their life better
whether it's me
as a son i call my mom more i call my
nephews more
but i struggle like holly does where
there are certain times where i go
is this just me being apathetic is this
bypass where i'm bypassing these larger
issues
to be like i'm nice to the guy at
starbucks when like i should be able to
do both
things right and so i'm trying to find
that balance where i i will still engage
a little politically but
to what kim was saying too i don't uh
facebook twitter
that's not actually being people think
that's being politically active
but because it tapes the form of doing
something but you're not actually
exactly you're you're having toxic
arguments with
strangers with frog memes or like in
their twitter profile and it's like is
this really me standing up for democracy
as opposed to i would rather be a little
less informed a little on social media
less
still have my values intact because by
the way when i was on twitter
there were some times when i'm like i
have this thought and i don't know if my
liberal friends are gonna like this or i
have this thought and i don't want rogan
to see it or whatever and i wouldn't
tweet it
so i was still like i wasn't actually
making up my own mind whereas now
consuming less i'm actually more
sort of uh firm in where i stand where
i'm like oh i believe these things
because
i believe these things also when we're
tied to an outcome
i think it's a bit of a problem here
right yeah so ryan um
i know you and i probably differ on this
a little bit so i'm interested to hear
your your thoughts and then we can have
the group
weigh in here uh very recently we've
seen these campaigns of make sure you
get out and
vote and some even say it doesn't even
matter who you vote for as long as you
vote
right i see that but that seems
incredibly disingenuous to me but
why i mean i at least respect someone
like uh
you know dan savage or a
you know uh ben shapiro who tell you go
out and vote for
mike's candidate yeah um or else stay at
home
right right and and that's kind of what
they're saying but when someone says
just get out and vote it's your duty to
vote
i i don't know that like i don't know
why that's constantly being thrust upon
me as though it's my
my duty to vote yeah no i think for me
i was raised uh being discouraged to
vote
um as a job as witness i mean they are
very politically
neutral which is funny because it's
you know in theory you can stay
politically neutral but in practice like
you're political whether you vote or not
yes so
growing up and being discouraged to vote
um i feel like it was a huge disservice
to myself
so i encourage people to get involved in
democracy
and i don't see how that could ever be a
bad thing to encourage people to get
involved with democracy
because when because when i say hey go
out and vote i truly do mean like hey
look this is a privilege
democracy is a privilege participate
yeah yeah so jonathan says is it
acceptable if i intentionally
choose not to vote
now tk what are you what are your
thoughts on this yeah
can i can i get a little something in i
want to read about the the first part of
that question yeah go for it
the whole responsibility part of like
consuming a bunch of yeah
this is from uh lori boxer's um
um swamp gas and it's called news at
eleven
and uh all right here we go ladies and
gentlemen the news at eleven
channel one had a special about yellow
alert so i worried a lot don't want to
get hurt
channel 2 said the flu was going around
so i got a flu shot and went out of town
channel 3 said those flu shots were
dangerous too so i turned on channel 4
to find out what to do
they said see a doctor so i could
survive in the waiting room i waited and
watched channel 5.
channel 5 and a tranquilizer made me
feel fine those soap opera problems are
much worse than mine
but at home channel 6 had a story about
pills and how people dropped dead from
prescription
from prescription or thrills so i call
back the doctor as i watch channel 7
a star was in rehab news at 11. so i
went into rehab where i watched channel
8 all about crime and murder and hate
and when i got home i tuned in channel 9
and watched blood and horror on some
battle line
i took a deep breath and scream and then
gave up and fainted as i watched channel
10
when the paramedics woke me the answer
was clear so i kill my tv and stop
living in fear
if you have a responsibility at all i
think you have a responsibility
to uncouple from any conversations or
form of content consumption
that is distracting you from making
investments in your purpose and in your
potential
yeah the best way to make the world
better is to make yourself better
focus on the things within your locus of
control and then challenge
other people to become better human
beings in ways that transcend
telling them how immoral they are for
not voting in the way that you want them
to vote
so much moralizing i agree with that in
practice
and while i can obviously tell kim like
what your views are
as you express them eloquently on your
youtube channel
what i don't see there is a a moralizing
that i see from a lot of these people
whether it's a dave rubin or a sam
cedar there's like a moralizing of
of course i'm right and wrong but when i
look at someone like tk he's not saying
there's a right
or wrong he's saying that i'm going to
improve
myself yeah i mean we all have different
life experiences and that's where we're
drawing
all of our our perspectives from right
and each of us have you know we're
walking in our own shoes as they say and
you if you don't if you want to know
what somebody else is thinking and walk
a mile in theirs which we can't really
actually do
so you know i don't think that there is
a lot of for me
the way that i look at things is i just
try to figure out why a person has the
perspective they're having where are
they coming from in order to get to that
point
yes yeah and that's so huge because
something we haven't talked about
is if you want to change someone's mind
you know what i mean like
calling someone a nazi they're probably
not going to be like all right i'm
listening
they're out i'm a nazi tell me more yeah
you're yelling at each other on twitter
now
um as opposed to i want to
find out why you're voting for trump
because maybe you're not a racist maybe
you actually
you know there are a lot of places where
obama and trump won
in the same district and it's like right
because obama ran against the
establishment on change
trump is the ultimate anti-establishment
there has to be some truth and a
conspiracy for people to believe the
conspiracy so when trump talked about
fake news when trump talked about
the swamp he was right about the
the the problem maybe not about the
solution maybe he was part of that swamp
maybe his family lives in the swamp
but there was a swamp right and so
people were outraged and they knew the
system was broken and so they went okay
i want to understand that because i
probably have a lot in common with trump
people
and then we can talk about you know look
there are certain issues to me that are
not
political that should not be democrat
and republican racism homophobia sexism
they are political the politics simply
means the affairs of the people right
right but what i mean
it shouldn't be about sides that should
be something where we all gather around
we're like yeah racism is bad we should
stop it not
hey there's a racist candidate and
there's a not racist candidate or
there's a racist party and a not racist
party
to jamie's point i remember one time
when britney spears first came out
and i heard her music and everybody was
going crazy over it right and i remember
saying man people are just stupid
people like this they're just stupid and
my my brother lamar said the following
to me he said
if your explanation for why a whole
bunch of people like something that you
don't like or understand
is that they're just stupid then you're
the one that's stupid
right and you can't get better in life
you can't get smarter in life
unless you do the hard work necessary to
understand
why people think differently than you on
issues that are very sensitive and so i
think jamie's absolutely right
most political discussion centers around
slam dunking on people
preaching to the choir and not genuinely
understanding yes
hey why do you think the way you do you
know but we make progress by having that
kind of
tk i'm not going to let you get away
from this question we're going to
save it for the maximum is it acceptable
if i intentionally
choose not to vote we're going to save
that because we need to move on to
well what time is it you know what time
it is it is time for the lightning round
where we answer your text messages you
can text your questions and comments too
937-202-4
yes indeed those taxes go to both of our
phones we answer as many as we can we
also answer some on the podcast
here now during the lightning round you
all have been previous guests before so
you probably remember it's
140 characters or less we we uh we try
to
sum it up in something pithy but not
really i don't have a twitter account
for a reason
i'm so bad at it you'll be the like
person who's like one out of 24
tweets we just monitor on a bit until we
figure
out something pithy that that podcast
sean can tweeze out put in the show
notes so you can copy and share our
pithy answers on social media if you
like and now
you can find all of our minimal maxims
in one place minimalmaxims.com ryan we
have a question from elizabeth
is this really the best we have to offer
or is the system so broken that the best
and brightest are excluded from
political leadership
because responsible conscientious
ethical people are eliminated early on
or
simply can't afford the outrageous
budget required to compete as
a candidate here's my pithy answer for
you all and then i'll let you unpack it
here
a corrupt system does not make room for
the truth uh my pithy answer is she was
right
tweet that this is not the best we have
well
yeah i mean the system blocks out
like we have heard from people who have
like andrew yang tulsi gabber right they
made a lot of noise on social media
because they were going against party
orthodoxy
and what happened they're russian agents
right instead of
even if i don't agree with everything
tulsi uh says even if i don't agree with
anything andrew yang says they're both
saying things that are kind of different
and that's cool and what if we like
apply like what if biden took yang's
universal income
what if uh uh another democrat
was like yeah tulsi is kind of right we
were the anti-war party
why are we suddenly you know what i'm
saying like there are ways that we
should be able to take from these voices
or
i mean again back to nader like they
didn't let homeboy in the debate
they learned with ross perot this is
what happens when you get
a third voice in the debate and it kind
of shakes things up and we don't like it
and the establishment wants to keep
things establishment so she's kind of
right
yeah i don't know when i see things like
unity 2020 getting uh
you know muted on twitter i mean it's
are you guys familiar with the
university 2020 thing no it's no no i'm
not
it's the it's what um which weinstein i
always forget which one it is
[Music]
one of the weinstein brothers started
this this movement where it's
you take a candidate from the republican
side and a candidate from the democratic
side and you create a unity ticket
and then one and they do a coin toss to
decide which one is president which
one's vice
and then at the end of the four years if
they win then they have to reverse roles
so i think this year it was dan crenshaw
and tulsi gabbard
yes were the two picks so tulsi from the
democratic side and dan crenshaw from
the republican and then
they would form this unity ticket the
idea is that then
this would unify america that these
would be candidates that people could
get behind
and that people would realize that we
don't live in such a polarized two-party
system
it's kind of a way to oh and uh one of
the um
important aspects of it is getting on
the ballot because ballot access is a
real problem for third parties
and so what the unity 2020 movement was
going to do was try to get
um the libertarian party actually has
more ballot access in more states than
green
but green does have some 20-something
states that they're on the
ballot for so unity 2020's idea was then
to go and petition
um basically the libertarian or green
party in each state
to try to get on the ballot for them
yeah to be the candidates for their
for their i think libertarian would be
more likely to do it but i don't because
green
has got some issues going on internally
right now i'm not sure if they would but
it's a good idea not sure if it would
actually work in
practice and you also obviously you need
a lot of money and just
to the question money it takes money
and i think this just goes to show that
money cannot buy anything
right right like a really good candidate
matt how gross is it whenever
you see how much like the mainstream
democrats or republicans
spent and you just think about how many
people we could have fed
with that you know especially right now
i know i know and it's just it's
just to get a bunch of just to get two
candidates that no one's happy with
hey maybe maybe it actually takes a lot
of money to get a bad candidate
um
you can tweet that podcast on yeah
that's good go ahead though
although it's fashionable to say people
are stupid i don't think people are
stupid no
i think people know when someone's lying
to them or not
people know when somebody's speaking
straight and
in order to suppress the truth in order
to prevent people from discovering the
truth
it takes a heck of a lot of effort to
drown out the voice of truth
right um it was i believe it was g.k
chesterton who spoke of the truth being
so dangerous that
it has to be surrounded by a bodyguard
of lies
and so one of the ways that you push the
voices of truth
who call out the corruption in the
system right
who who say the things that we're
uncomfortable hearing and saying
ourselves
you you drown them out you you put a
price tag on everything
and you say hey you got to have this
much money if you even want to
participate in the debate
right think about how much money is
spent just in
keeping certain voices from even
participating in debates
so that we can't see biden or trump
being challenged by a different way of
thinking yeah i think
i think it takes a lot of money to keep
the poor people in town
incompetent people that's a great point
it's interesting how bloomberg
bought his way into the like if you have
you know if you have enough money to
know the right people you can buy your
way into the debates i mean it's to go
nowhere yeah no one wanted blueberries
and then so much money it goes even
beyond that
once you're in you know for example
congress once you're in congress and
you've been elected then it takes money
to get on the committee seats
so to become speaker of the house that's
not because the person you know
is the best leader from that party that
is not the reason why they're speaker of
the house
they're speaker of the house because
they raised the most money and that is
well known
inside of congress on both sides they do
this if you want to be on
the top committee then you have to raise
a certain amount of money and give that
money back to the party
and it's actually printed out they're
handed this saying if this is the
committee seating you if you want this
assignment
this is what it's going to cost you and
then by the way they leave office they
become lobbyists
right they're all these cushy jobs make
a ton of money then they go back
campaign with their friends who are
still in office and it's like it's money
money money we don't learn our lesson to
quote britney spears oops i did it again
here's here i'm gonna tell i just wanna
read my pithy answer here my pithy
answer is this focus less on government
and more on contributing beyond yourself
in a meaningful way and this makes you
think about what you were saying cam
about looking
through it uh trying to put yourself in
someone else's shoes
because ultimately what that leads us to
do is show compassion and i think that
is what america is lacking right now and
personally i would much rather people
go out of their way to show compassion
than go vote so that's the one exception
where i'll be like
voting isn't as important as showing
compassion you could tweet that
yeah i don't think a person should vote
if they don't know what they're voting
about yes that is absolutely yeah that's
a great point
yeah yeah i don't hear that talked about
at all yes brilliant well maybe we can
talk about this in the maximal but i
i said this to josh the other day and he
was like i think tk's gonna disagree
with you
but i because you're not voting and i i
what i told him was is
it seems like it's not it doesn't really
make sense to me when someone goes off
and rants about politics when they
didn't vote in the election it's like in
order to have
an opinion that matters you should vote
and
maybe we cover this in the maximal but i
wanted to get your take on that because
he challenged me on it and i actually
did kind of backpedal a little bit but
i would love to talk about that a little
bit more all right before we get into
our listener
tips today it looks like we got a bunch
more surprise questions this week like
when is it okay to be out of touch
what's the best argument against
democracy
when is it okay not to vote
can we have compassion for someone we
disagree with
if joshua was earth czar what are three
ways he'd
fix our broken political system i think
we'll posit that question for everyone
as well
who did the minimalists vote for in 2016
and who are they voting for
now plus a million more questions for
kim tk
and jamie and the minimalists and if you
want to hear all that subscribe to our
maximal episodes on the minimalist
private podcast it's a
completely separate podcast and it's the
most honest way for the minimalist to
earn an income because we don't believe
in advertisements
by the way if you're not a private
podcast subscriber
you're literally missing two-thirds of
our show plus hundreds of hours
of past private episodes so try it out
for a week
or a month it's cheaper than a cup of
coffee head on over to the
minimalists.com support to subscribe
and get your personal link so that our
private podcast plays in your
favorite podcast app that's
theminimalists.com
support ryan what else you got for us
this week here are some voicemail
comments and tips from our listeners
check them out josh and ryan hey it's
erin professional makeup artist
i've seen my fair share of tips tricks
trends looks and products in my past
decade of being in this industry
i've been a practicing minimalist for
the past four years thanks to you guys
and one of my favorite things to do is
trickle over what i know from personal
minimalism
into professional minimalism in the
beauty industry as it really needs
help there one of my favorite things
that i do with my clients
is refurbish vintage compacts
i find them in antique stores and
vintage shops and they might have
personal heirloom vintage compacts from
past family members and then i install
magnetic backing into the compacts
and use refillable products my line
included
that go into those vintage compacts so
this means we don't have any plastic
packaging
we're not throwing out the packaging
when the actual products
run out and you have something much more
beautiful and durable
than anything in today's creations it
also encourages people to use what they
have
before buying something new because
there's only so much that'll fit into
the vintage compacts
the last perk it's 100 customizable so
you're not
hoarding shades you won't use hello
this is keegan calling from ogden utah i
wanted to share
three quotes which add a ton of value in
my life currently
and help guide my journey with
minimalism the first one is one that i
hear often on the podcast which is the
question what would my life be like with
less
the second is a quote i heard by
leonardo da vinci which says simplicity
is the ultimate sophistication the third
and by far my most favorite is a phrase
i saw on
product packaging for an alcoholic
beverage
which said consume responsibly
these two words can be applied in so
many ways that promote intentional
living and minimalist values
all right y'all thanks again to kim
iverson check her out kim iverson's show
on youtube
we'll put a link to that in the show
notes as well also jamie kilstein
his podcast is called a [ __ ] ups guide
to self-help
he also has a new comedy album coming
out december 8th we'll put a link to
that
in the show notes as well you can follow
him on social media to
get updates about that and of course the
reigning champion tk
coleman revolution of one it's uh
fee.org
rev1 is his podcast and really it's like
a tv show you can check out the video
version as well
we'll put a link to that in the show
notes also you have a conference
online conference coming up you want to
talk about that real quick yes global
entrepreneurship week is the week of
november 16th
and on that week we will be hosting
a number of different panel discussions
and talks that teach people how to
become the ceo of their own life and how
to introduce
entrepreneurial thinking to the
conflicts and challenges that they have
i love it you can follow tk coleman on
twitter at tk
underscore coleman make sure you put
that underscore in there otherwise
you're going to follow a different tk
coleman
very different brother you can follow
the minimalists on facebook twitter and
instagram at the minimalists
come to one of our live podcast shows
visit the minimalists.com
tour to find a city near you if you have
a question comment or minimalism tip for
our podcast
email a voice memo to podcast at
theminimalists.com
you can comment on this episode at
youtube.com slash the minimalist if you
want our show notes in your inbox
sign up for our email list over at
theminimalists.com you'll also receive
our simple sunday emails
whenever we send those and if you leave
here today with just one message we hope
it's this
love people and use things
because the opposite never works thanks
for listening y'all we'll see you next
time
every little thing you think that you
need
every little thing you think that you
need
every little thing that's just feeding
your greed oh i bet that you'll be fine
without it